bonsoir à tous dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir notre grand témoin et la présidente
du groupe la France insoumise à
l'Assemblée Mathilde panot bonsoir à
vous ensemble on évoquera dans quelques
instants bien sûr la réforme des
retraites puisque l'Inter syndical était
reçu pour la première fois depuis le
début de cette réforme par Elisabeth
borne à Matignon on se penchera aussi
sur l'avenir de la Nupe et sur la place
que tient elle est fi dans cette
alliance politique alors que Fabien
Roussel juge que la nuque est désormais
dépassée mais avant cela on va se
pencher en détail sur la stratégie du
maintien de l'ordre en France alors que
Gérald Darmanin était entendu ce matin
par les députés de la commission des
lois sur ce sujet assiste-t-on à une
forme de brutalisation du maintien de
l'ordre en France question importante
qui met en jeu à la fois l'étape droit
et nos libertés publiques enfin 20h15 on
aura bien sûr les parties prix de nos
affranchis et la chronique Bourbon
Express qui est signée aujourd'hui
d'Elsa mondain Gava voilà pour le menu
vous me suivez
[Musique]
la France pays des droits de l'homme qui
est pointé du doigt à l'étranger et le
Conseil de l'Europe s'inquiète d'un
usage excessif de la force contre les
manifestants même mis en garde de la
part du rapporteur spécial des Nations
Unies pour la liberté d'association
alors la France doit-elle revoir sa
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre on en
débat avec nos invités et j'accueille
pour cela Anne-Sophie Saint-Père bonsoir
vous avez travaillé pour Amnesty
International pendant quelques années
sur les questions du maintien de l'ordre
et des violences policières et votre
dernier livre s'intitule comment l'État
s'attaque à nos libertés chez plomb
Alain Vastel bonsoir vous êtes
secrétaire national du syndicat CRS
Unité SGP Police FO
à vos côtés Matthieu Lefebvre bonsoir
vous êtes député renaissance du
Val-de-Marne et par ailleurs ancien chef
de cabinet de Gérald Darmanin au
ministère de l'Intérieur et puis face à
vous Alexandra Masson bonsoir vous êtes
député rassemblement national des
Alpes-Maritimes et porte-parole du RN et
puis notre grand témoin que je vous ai
présenté tout à l'heure Mathilde panot
vous intervenez évidemment quand vous
voulez sur ce débat lié au maintien de
l'ordre mais pour commencer la chronique
de Stéphane blackovski qui a 200
secondes pour nous faire bien comprendre
pourquoi en débat de cette question ce
soir
vers vous
bonsoir Clément vous accueillir bonsoir
Stéphane donc ce soir on parle des
violences policières et je vous préviens
tout de suite ça sera pas possible de
mettre tout le monde d'accord déjà rien
que là j'ai dit violence policière et ça
peut être au début d'une polémique il y
a des gens qui disent les violences
policières ça n'existe pas mais pas plus
tard que ce matin Gérard Larcher le
président du Sénat était sur BFM il a
dit non il y a pas de violence policière
ce qui est effectivement aussi la
position de du ministre de l'Intérieur
qui dit il y a des policiers violents ça
oui comme partout mais il y a pas de
violence dans l'institution policière
bon cela dit ça c'est la barre
officielle on n'est pas obligé de faire
l'autruche suffit de regarder sur les
réseaux sociaux la violence policière je
sais pas comment appeler ça mais
regardez là c'est pas à gauche de
l'écran il y a un policier qui traverse
la chaussée et on sait pas trop pourquoi
il va coller un immense coup de poing à
ce jeune mais alors immense donc ça
c'est pas du tout du tout de du maintien
de l'ordre ça n'a rien à voir donc même
à l'étranger tout le monde s'en rend
bien compte vous l'avez dit au début on
a été épinglé montré du doigt comme vous
voudrez par les Nations unies par le
Conseil de l'Europe je vous ai gardé le
meilleur pour la fin c'est inattendu
même par la Maison Blanche qui nous dit
quand même on pourrait manifester
pacifiquement en France bon sur pareil
quand on se regarde on se désole c'est
quand on se prépare éventuellement se
consoler donc les Américains sont pas
les mieux placés pour nous faire la
leçon sur les violences policières vous
voyez il y a eu plus de 1000 personnes
tuées aux États-Unis l'an dernier par
les policiers trois par jour donc on en
est pas là en France les chiffres il
date de 2021 c'est ceux de l'IGPN 37
décès le problème c'est que justement ce
sont les chiffres de l'IGPN donc c'est
un service de la police qui enquête sur
la police ils sont un peu jugés partis
peut-être que c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait changer mais même avec les
chiffres on va jamais réussir à se
mettre d'accord donc ce qu'on pourrait
faire c'est se tourner dans les sondages
c'est ce qu'on fait pour la réforme des
retraites on dit il y a plus de 60% des
Français qui sont posés à la réforme
donc bah retirons là alors sur les
violences policières ben du coup on
devrait pouvoir pas on devrait pas
parler de violences policières parce que
pour les Français
à plus de 60% c'est il y a des policiers
qui dérapent mais il y a pas une
violence comme ça dans la police donc
après on peut évidemment s'en tenir là
mais il y a quand même un clivage dans
la société et je remercie le panneau il
est un peu entretenu par les filles je
pense parce que on voit qu'il y a une
différence entre les sympathisants et
les filles il reste des Français
notamment sur l'opinion qu'on peut avoir
de la police vous allez voir pour
l'ensemble des Français ils ont une
opinion positive à 58% c'est pas énorme
mais enfin chez les sympathisants et les
filles ce n'est que 32 % et ça s'inverse
vous voyez l'opinion négative dans
l'ensemble des Français et de 27% et
chez les filles ça monte à 56% une
majorité des sympas disant une image
négative de la police donc on pourrait
se dire si on condamne la violence de la
police on va pas supporter la violence
des manifestants c'est un peu plus
ambigu parce que regardez sur la
question de est-ce qu'on a le droit de
être violent pour défendre ses idées ben
pour l'ensemble des Français c'est non à
65%, mais pour les sympathisants et les
filles bah oui des fois si on veut
vraiment les bouts de ses idées il faut
avoir recours à la violence donc oui
forcément ça paraît un peu paradoxal si
on condamne la violence de la police on
se dit peut-être il faudrait refuser la
violence de la minimité ce temps je pose
juste la question je pense que vous
allez débattre là-dessus sans vous mais
merci à vous Stéphane blackowski je
commence par vous Mathieu Lefevre en
voyant ces images montrer la par
Stéphane à l'instant est-ce que
vous-même vous vous interrogez sur la
stratégie du maintien de l'ordre sur les
méthodes qui peuvent être employées
parfois par les policiers dans le cadre
de ces manifestations d'abord avoir une
pensée pour les plus de 1000 policiers
gendarmes que vous n'avez pas cités qui
ont été blessés et souvent violemment
blessés certains sont sur des tables on
va parler de la violence à laquelle ils
sont confrontés évidemment ça fait
partie de notre débat ils font face à un
déferlement de violence inouï depuis
notamment le 16 mars dernier mais ce
qu'on oublie un petit peu dans ce débat
c'est quand on nous dit qu'il y a de la
violence elle est pas du fait du
maintien de l'ordre s'il y a maintien de
l'ordre c'est parce qu'il y a des ordres
il faut pas inverser les choses dans
notre pays en revanche monsieur
Tchaikovski parlait de violences
policières je récuse totalement ce terme
il n'y a pas de violence policière il y
a des policiers qui peuvent déraper qui
peuvent abuser de leur autorité
administrative et pour ça il y a des
sanctions qui sont prévues et ces
sanctions elles sont très fortes et
elles sont infligées immédiatement mais
parler de violences policières c'est
jeter nos propres sur une profession qui
est dédiée à la République et qui prend
beaucoup de risques pour défendre la
République donc Stéphane dacowski lui a
repris le terme de violences policières
parce qu'il était rejeté par Gérard
Larcher et par Gérald Darmanin et vous
êtes sur cette ligne là on va au débat
j'imagine sur ce plateau notamment avec
vous Mathilde pano parce que de votre
côté vous avez un point de vue différent
sur ce sur ce sujet là déjà il faut il
faut remettre des choses déjà je vous
remercie de la manière dont ça a été
posé au début parce que la France
insoumise est souvent présentée comme
une force qui est antipolyse antiflic ou
je ne sais quoi ce n'est pas du tout le
cas et d'ailleurs je remarque que les
policiers qui sont par leurs ordres
obligés de réprimer des manifestations
vous avez bon vous pouvez parler on peut
on peut égrainer beaucoup de noms que ça
soit Cédric chouvia ou autre sur des
problèmes de violence policière mais
même attendez plus récemment vous
trouvez normal qu'une mère de famille
aesh perd d'un pouce parce qu'elle est
en train de manifester vous trouvez
normal qu'un cheminot perd d'un œil
parce qu'il est en train de manifester
en 2023 c'est ça la question qui est
posée et donc ça ne sert à rien de faire
l'autruche la question c'est quels sont
les règles qu'on se donne on arrête
d'instrumentaliser la police on interdit
les armes qui sont mutilantes on fait de
la formation la désescalade on va
prendre tous ces sujets un par un si
vous voulez bien je voudrais d'abord
avoir votre point de vue à vous
Alexandra Masson pour le rassemblement
national est-ce qu'il y a des questions
aujourd'hui qui se posent sur la
stratégie de maintien de l'ordre est-ce
que les images là qu'on vient de voir et
vous interpellent
fortement c'est ces images parce qu'on
voit des images effectivement de
violence et on sait que actuellement il
y a effectivement des violences sur tous
ces manifestations entre autres qu'il y
a eu sur les retraites puis on pourra
reparler sur Sainte Soline moi je pense
à tous les gendarmes et un métier qui
regarde ce type d'image ils sont en
train dans leur fauteuil de se dire et
où sont les images où on se fait
agresser avec une violence extrême ces
images-là en ce moment sur les réseaux
sociaux on ne les voit nulle part or
elles existent hors ces gens sont en
souffrance on les a désormais depuis des
années la violence de certains
manifestants peut justifier certains
dérapages individuels rien ne justifie
jamais la violence rien que ça soit du
côté des forces de l'ordre ou du côté
des personnes qui manifestent jamais
rien ne manif ne doit arriver à la
violence on parle de maintien de l'ordre
si on parle de maintien de l'ordre c'est
qu'à un moment donné on se retrouve dans
une situation de crise on est obligé de
ramener l'ordre comme on est en train de
l'indiquer pour amener l'ordre et là
c'est triste à dire et bien oui la
violence elle peut arriver qu'il y ait
des dérapages évidemment il peut
toujours y en avoir les forces de
l'ordre comme tout organisme à un moment
donné sont là pour maintenir l'ordre il
peut y avoir individuellement une ou
deux personnes qui peuvent déraper je
vous rappelle quand même c'est important
ça n'a pas été dit hélas mais c'est une
profession qui est extrêmement contrôlée
extrêmement contrôlé et de manière
régulière qui souvent sanctionnée et
d'ailleurs Darmanin qui pourtant ne fait
pas partie des personnes que
politiquement
public et 55 % des sanctions
administratives c'est le corps le
contrôle par rapport au nombre
d'affaires sur l'année combien moi
j'aimerais avoir ce chiffre là on va on
va on va tour de table si vous voulez
bien
magistrat aujourd'hui qui est qui a été
nommé donc tout à l'heure vous l'avez
dit effectivement les JPN c'est un peu
la police des polices mais aujourd'hui
c'est un magistrat donc quand même n'a
pas le même parcours qui a été nommé et
je pense que c'est quand même malgré
tout un signal favorable mais il faut
vous rendre compte que ce que vous avez
montré n'est pas la réalité
on ne sait pas tout à l'heure
comment vous pouvez savoir si je suis
pas aux manifestations c'est que vous
regardez pas l'actualité quand tout à
l'heure vous voyez un policier qui
effectivement agresse comme ça quelqu'un
mais où sont les séquences avant
peut-être qu'ils se sont croisés avant
on ne sait pas on monte des séquences
comme ça momentané on sait absolument
pas ce qui a pu se passer avant
peut-être rien mais peut-être quelque
chose et c'est ça aujourd'hui comment
est-ce que vous vivez vous ce débat
comment est-ce qu'il est vécu par vos
collègues c'est RS est-ce que vous
ressentez ça comme une remise en cause
un justifiée de votre travail bah
clairement clairement enfin le niveau
d'engagement aujourd'hui des forces de
l'ordre sur tout le territoire national
parce qu'on fait des focus sur la
capitale bien évidemment mais ça ça se
passe sur tout le territoire national le
niveau de violence auquel on est
confronté était énorme énorme mais il
est pas du fait de tous les manifestants
encore une fois faut bien rappeler que
la grande majorité des manifestants le
font de la dans la paix la plus la plus
possible en fin de compte et c'est juste
le fait de quelques radicaux qui
viennent agresser et avec une
détermination telle aujourd'hui que
effectivement quand mes collègues
croisent le regard il voit bien qu'il y
a une détestation profonde
Anne-Sophie Saint-Père vous avez une
vision assez critique je crois du
maintien de l'ordre à la française comme
on dit aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
entendez aussi ces arguments employés là
par Alain reste elle savoir que ils sont
les forces de l'ordre sont confrontées à
un niveau de violence jusqu'à présent
inégalé et que la réponse doit être
proportionnée à la violence qui est
adressée alors clairement le travail des
forces de l'ordre est extrêmement
difficile les forces de l'ordre sont
confrontées à des violences ça n'est pas
un niveau de violence inégalée je vous
invite à regarder des manifestations de
sidérurgistes ou de marins-pêcheurs dans
les années 80-70 c'était extrêmement
violent pour les forces de l'ordre mais
68 ça n'a pas été purement Pacifique je
vous invite à regarder ce qui se passe
dans d'autres pays il y a aussi l'une
des manifestations très violentes des
voitures brûlées contre les mesures
sanitaires aux Pays-Bas donc ça n'est
pas l'apanage de la France ça n'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'il y a des violences en
manifestations français mais c'est quand
même un problème pour vous alors par
contre le maintien de l'ordre en France
n'est pas bon le bilan n'est pas bon par
le nombre de blessés du côté des de
l'ordre comme du côté des manifestants
avec en plus le fait que du côté des
manifestants il y a des blessures qui
sont extrêmement graves des mutilations
il y a des manifestants qui sont tués
j'ai entendu que la police était
désarmée en fait on est une police qui
est parmi les plus armées d'Europe de
l'Ouest et notamment on utilise des
armes qui sont susceptibles de mutiler
contre des foules donc ça c'est
extrêmement grave et ça c'est pas le cas
chez nos voisins c'est pas le cas chez
nos voisins il y a pas que ça dans le
maintien de l'ordre il y a aussi la
question des arrestation arbitraire
puisqu'on a des arrestations massives
avec des taux extrêmement élevés de
personnes qui sont relâchées sans suite
et alors on a regardé un peu qu'il y
avait été arrêté ce sont les étudiants
un agent immobilier un graphiste enfin
voilà c'est pas de ville incasser il y a
des interdictions massives très larges
de manifester qui sont publiées
tardivement dans des
manifestants qui reçoivent des
verbalisations sans avoir pu être
informé de l'interdiction de manifester
le bilan il est pas bon ensuite ce bilan
et cette stratégie de maintien de
l'ordre elle n'est pas choisie par les
forces de l'ordre sur le terrain c'est
un choix politique qui vise à réprimer
les manifestations et c'est assez
inquiétant puis qu'aujourd'hui on est
quand même dans un blocage politique
avec la réforme des retraites et ce
n'est pas la répression policière qui va
résoudre cette situation on va débat de
tout ça mais avant j'aimerais quand même
qu'on fasse un point sur ce qui s'est
dit ce matin en commission des lois avec
le ministre de l'Intérieur qui est donc
le principal concerné par cette
stratégie de maintien de l'ordre qui
était auditionné par les députés qui
répondaient à leurs questions pendant
plus de deux heures on va voir avec Tibo
inox ce qu'il faut en retenir
des vidéos à Lyon on voit évidemment que
ce soit des pavés qui sont jetés de
façon assez impressionnante des photos
et quelques images saccage d'une mairie
d'arrondissement à Lyon et des chiffres
1851 interpellation pendant plus de deux
heures Gérald darmanens ce matin à
justifier la fermeté du maintien de
l'ordre ces dernières semaines face aux
critiques le ministre a renvoyé la
responsabilité de la violence constatée
au casseurs des avis de renseignement
aux documenté désormais ce n'est pas
contesté l'ultra gauche a infiltré une
partie des revendications pour les
radicaliser et ça a été notamment le cas
à Paris le ministre a aussi dû répondre
au sujet des bravesm sévèrement critiqué
à gauche la brave m sème la terreur
chaque soir dans les rues de Paris cette
unités de police ou les policiers se
comportent comme des miliciens
faudra-t-il un nouveau Malikou cekin
pour enfin vous faire revenir la raison
Gérald Darmanin a défendu l'existence de
ces brigades motorisées
quand on veut dissout de la bravance ça
peut étonnant parce que ça n'existe pas
c'est pas une unité le problème c'est
des personnes qui sont des compagnies
d'intervention donc évidemment fondateur
j'ai vu fleurir le fait qu'il n'était
pas formé au maintien de l'ordre ils
sont évidemment formés à votre chatboard
et parallèles avec des affaires
dramatiques il y a 30 ou 40 ans son nom
outrancier bien insultant autre réponse
attendue sur le maintien de l'ordre à
Sainte Soline là encore c'est la
radicalité de certains manifestants qui
expliquent et justifient la réplique
policière à estimer le ministre à ses
yeux la réponse était proportionnée et
légitime l'objectif qui avait été défini
c'était non seulement de détruire les
bassines et les préparations des
bassines mais d'occuper le site par une
zone au non droit et vous savez si
jamais les dirigeants correspondu
arriver les
Ultra gauche à Notre-Dame-des-Landes
avaient eu le même réaction que ce
gouvernement si il y aurait pas eu
Notre-Dame-des-Landes des réponses
contester sur les bancs de la gauche
vous avez évoqué des mots et des images
vous avez oublié bien des faits c'est
cent aines de garder à vue qui ressort
sans aucune poursuite preuve de leur
innocence c'est mutiler ces manifestants
dans le coma monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur vous avez esquivé ce matin
vos responsabilités reconnaissant
quelques fautes individuelles le
ministre a cependant annoncé avoir
demandé personnellement trois enquêtes
sur des manquements aux règles de
maintien de l'ordre en plus des 41 cas
dont tu as déjà été saisi l'inspection
de la police nationale
Mathilde pano si on résume les propos de
Gérald Darmanin il explique qu'à ses
yeux il y a pas de problème de stratégie
de maintien de l'ordre aujourd'hui en
France que le problème il vient de
l'ultra gauche qui infiltre les
manifestations et qui prend en otage en
quelque sorte les manifestants qu'est-ce
que vous lui répondez déjà moi je suis
très inquiète du glissement qu'on
observe dans notre pays aujourd'hui sur
la question de l'État de droit et des
libertés ou finalement des
manifestations ne seraient plus
autorisées et un droit constitutionnel
comme le droit de grève mais simplement
toléré et avec une forme de brutalité
alors on a la brutalité sur l'Assemblée
nationale c'est le 49.3 la brutalité
avec une instrumentalisation de la
police sur les manifestations et la
brutalité sur le droit de grève avec les
réquisitions
la première des choses c'est que
Monsieur Darmanin est bien silencieux
sur les violences de l'extrême droite
dans notre pays qui sont en augmentation
constante et je rappelle juste que par
exemple la mairie de Bordeaux qui à
juste titre affoler toute une partie des
médias il a été prouvé que c'était des
militants d'extrême droite qui avait mis
le feu et moi j'aimerais que on dise des
choses dessus la deuxième chose c'est
que Monsieur Darmanin lorsqu'il utilise
des mots comme terrorisme intellectuel
lorsqu'il pointe des forces politiques
comme comme les nôtres c'est un problème
démocratique puissant qu'il est en train
de faire non seulement il nous insulte
nous il insulte les 8 millions de
personnes qui ont voté pour nous aux
élections présidentielles mais il est en
train de faire un glissement
démocratique qui est très grave et je le
dis pas ma question sur l'ultra gauche
présente dans les cortèges c'est un
problème répondre nous avons toujours
dit et je le redis encore ici nous avons
toujours dit que nous étions en
désaccord avec la violence sur
l'intégrité des personnes en politique
que en politique ce qui nous semblait
intéressant c'était de faire nombre avec
les millions de personnes qui
manifestent chaque semaine ou ça se
passe très bien et je dois dire que ce
qui est dit aujourd'hui et je j'aimerais
juste dire une dernière chose sur quand
on décale le le viseur regardez votre
collègue Suisse qui dit je suis
extrêmement choquée de voir les sortes
qui sont donnés de voir la police
chargée comme ça toute une foule de
manière complètement indistinte il dit
en Suisse nous avons des Black Blocs et
ça n'arrive jamais et je le dis il y
avait un groupe de recherche qui met les
à la fois des chercheurs et des
policiers pour travailler sur une
gestion pacifique des foules la France a
refusé d'y participer et pourtant dans
beaucoup d'autres pays vous n'avez pas
des gens qui perdent des yeux qui
perdent des mains c'est en manifestation
en 2023 on ne peut pas arriver à de
telles choses et donc c'est l'échec de
Monsieur Darmanin qui est responsable de
ce chaos c'est la question que j'allais
vous poser aussi Mathieu Lefebvre cette
ultra gauche elle représente quelques
centaines maximum un millier de
personnes par manifestation on peut le
dire des manifestations qui apparaît en
tout cas ont rassemblé 100.000 150 voire
200000 personnes par moment comment
jugez-vous la stratégie du maintien de
l'autre par rapport à cela est-ce que
elle n'est pas défaillante dès lors que
les forces de l'ordre n'arrivent pas à
neutraliser cette petite minorité le
maintien de l'ordre on marche un petit
peu sur la tête elle a aussi pour
protéger le droit de manifester
pacifiquement il y a d'un autre pays un
droit constitutionnel à manifester mais
il y a pas un droit à manifester
violemment et dans quel monde
vivons-nous on a l'impression que tout
s'envère son marche un petit peu sur la
tête on a l'impression que la violence
elle est du côté des forces de l'ordre
la violence pardon elle est du côté des
violents des gens qui jettent des pavés
à la tête des CRS des gens qui viennent
dans des manifestations est-ce que la
stratégie n'est pas défaillante dès lors
que la police n'arrive pas à neutraliser
ces éléments minoritaires mais dans les
cortèges je ne crois pas et encore une
fois je veux dire quelque chose qui peut
paraître choquant mais pour éviter de se
retrouver blessé dans une manifestation
illégale la première des choses c'est de
regarder le mot illégal et de ne pas s'y
rendre et moi je regrette que des
députés de votre groupe madame panot
s'il soit rendu nous sommes débutés de
la République et nous faisons la loi et
quand on fait la loi on ne se rend pas
dans une manifestation illégale c'est la
première des choses et au-delà de ça ce
qui est très important dans ce débat
vous avez quelque part commencé un
travail de sable de nos institutions qui
commencent par la police ensuite la
démocratie les institutions de la 5ème
de remettre en cause mais ce travail de
ça madame panot d'abord vous ne gagnerez
jamais ce combat parce que la démocratie
est plus forte que ce que vous faites
mais madame panneau quand Monsieur
Mélenchon dit que la police tue quand
Monsieur Mélenchon dit qu'il faut
rééduquer soigner les policiers de la
brave m et bien je vais vous dire une
chose c'est absolument scandaleux et
c'est une façon absolument intolérable
de faire rentrer la violence dans le
débat public quand des membres de votre
groupe jouent avec la tête d'un ministre
comme un ballon de foot quand on dit
qu'un ministre est un assassin il y en a
beaucoup mais là pour parler du maintien
de l'ordre pas pour refaire pas pour
refaire les débats qui ont eu lieu dans
l'hémicycle ce genre de tous les pays où
on arrive à détourner un cortège qui
serait éventuellement violent et à ne
pas Nasser gazer l'ensemble des gens qui
sont là et que dans notre pays on y
arrive bon il est gagné
depuis longtemps ce matin Gérald
Darmanin a expliqué qu'il y a eu deux
temps dans ce mouvement social contre la
réforme des retraites il y a eu l'avant
49-3 et l'après et qu'à partir du 16
mars la donne a changé est-ce que vous
CRS vous avez reçu des consignes
différentes à partir du 16 mars pour
gérer notamment ces manifestations un
peu sauvages on va dire qui qui se sont
multipliés bah non on ne reçoit pas de
consignes par anticipation vu que le
propre du matelas de l'ordre c'est de
s'adapter au temps qu'on traverse dans
l'instant donc et qui est une par
exemple la consigne d'interpeller
davantage de manifestants c'est une
quand on voit ce qui a été évoqué il y a
quelques instants c'est à dire du jour
au lendemain on se retrouve avec
plusieurs centaines de personnes
interpellées qui neuf fois sur 10 on va
dire à peu près sont remises en liberté
sans être suivi si je peux me permettre
juste rappeler que au départ le maintien
de l'ordre ça s'appelle de la gestion de
full au début c'est une police
administrative donc et en l'occurrence
depuis le 19 janvier c'est ce qui s'est
passé les cortèges étaient tenus par les
organisations syndicales il y a
quasiment pas eu de problème et ce sont
plein à un moment d'avoir été gazés sur
la tête de cortège ce qui arrive très
très rarement mais il y a eu des
on peut aussi amener dialogue il y a
peut-être des des parties sur lesquelles
on serait amené à progresser
particulièrement sur la communication à
l'endroit des manifestants je pense que
on n'est pas allé au bout il y a
peut-être d'autres moyens technologiques
aujourd'hui qui nous permettraient au
moins de permettre à ceux qui dans le
dialogue avec les responsables sur le
fait d'envoyer des SMS groupés comme ça
a été réfléchi une fois en Allemagne ils
font des grands panneaux publics
c'est déjà c'est déjà actuel aujourd'hui
parce que ça a été mis en place il y a
plus d'un an au niveau de la préfecture
de police de Paris c'est déjà quelque
chose qui est fait aujourd'hui et après
encore une fois les manifestations
lorsqu'elles sont déclarées elles
peuvent justement faire l'objet des
changes et d'un travail en amont sur la
définition du cortège de comment on
comment ça va se passer dès lors que
vous passez sur des manifestations qui
ne sont pas déclarés qui n'est pas un ça
réduit sérieusement le chant des
possibles autoriser pour une bonne
gestion du match
il y avait un problème sur la question
j'aimerais qu'on évoque avec vous aussi
le sujet de la formation des forces de
l'ordre au maintien de l'ordre est-ce
qu'elle est
au niveau si vous voulez pour toutes les
unités qui interviennent aujourd'hui
dans les manifestations on a vu la
bravème qui a été pointé du doigt à
plusieurs reprises on va en parler
d'ailleurs dans un instant est-ce qu'il
y a aujourd'hui des difficultés elles
ont été évoquées par Gérald Darmanin il
a dit ce matin il y a des difficultés de
formation maintien de l'ordre qu'il y
ait des difficultés de formation au
maintien de l'ordre c'est possible en
l'occurrence pour les CRS que je
représente moi aujourd'hui on a un socle
de formation annuelle qui est
incontournable qui est toujours respecté
et en l'occurrence c'est c'est un peu le
principe du schéma national de maintien
de l'ordre qui se veut commun à toutes
les forces mais en France mais est-ce
que tout ce qui sont dédiés seulement au
maintien de l'ordre c'est leur cœur de
métier elles sont formées en permanence
pour ça toutes les catégories de
policiers ou gendarmes qui interviennent
dans le maintien de l'ordre aujourd'hui
ont une formation qui vous que vous
jugez suffisante adaptée vous dire
quelle qu'elle soit suffisante je pense
qu'à la limite de toute façon la
répétition fait en sorte qu'on y a une
meilleure maîtrise obligatoirement
aujourd'hui les les policiers doivent
répondre à une charge missionnelle qui
est très importante et qu'à un moment
donné est-ce que le temps consacré à la
formation est suffisant je pense que
c'est jamais suffisant à temps la
réalité du thé du terrain est là on va
se pencher plus en détail si vous voulez
bien sûr le les braves m les brigades de
répression de l'action violente
motorisée qui ont été créées en 2019 au
moment des gilets jaunes elles sont donc
aujourd'hui accusées d'alimenter les
tensions dans les cortèges par leur mode
d'intervention et une pétition a été
lancée sur le site de l'Assemblée à la
recueilli à ce jour plus de 260 000
signatures elle réclament de dissoudre
cette brigade d'intervention une
pétition qui a été classée en classé
sans suite en quelque sorte aujourd'hui
par le député Renaissance Éric pouliac
qui était rapporteur de cette pestition
va on va écouter ses explications
il faut toutefois convenir que le
portrait des bras m que dresse la
pétition apparaît caricatura la
plusieurs titres
en premier lieu on ne peut pas contester
que des unités mobiles sont un
complément
utile aux traditionnels brigades de
maintien de l'ordre dans les
déplacements sont plus lents en second
lieu il faut rappeler que les bras même
n'ont ni pour objet ni pour effet de
restreindre la liberté de manifestation
le comportement fautif de quelques
agents qui font l'objet d'enquête en vue
de sanction ne peut pas conduire à
remettre en cause l'utilité des braves
dans leur ensemble
pour toutes ces raisons je vous propose
chers collègues de classer la pétition
en 1319 demandant la dissolution des
braves m alors Anne-Sophie Saint-Père si
on résume c'est un peu circuler il y a
rien à voir il y a pas de problème
aujourd'hui avec les braves m à vos yeux
il y a plusieurs vidéos qui indiquent
qu'il y a pu avoir des usagers légaux de
la force par les braves m je trouve ça
dommage de pas en débattre je ne pense
pas que le débat des crédits je pense
pas que la transparence les discussions
décrédibilise en revanche l'opacité à
une sensation d'impunité ça peut nuire à
l'image des forces de l'ordre donc
écarter d'un geste de main peut être
problématique ensuite je voulais revenir
sur des choses qui ont été dites et qui
m'inquiète on a mis en avant le fait que
les forces de l'ordre répondaient à des
violences et alors je vais pas nier
qu'il y a des violences contre les
forces de l'ordre bien évidemment mais
le fait qu'il y ait des violences de la
part de manifestants notorise pas tout
et les forces de l'ordre ont bien sûr le
droit d'utiliser la force mais dans le
cadre légal quand on parlait de
peut-être que dans l'image d'avant
plusieurs minutes avant il y a eu des
coups et donc ça justifierait un coup de
poing absolument pas la légitime défense
c'est une réponse immédiate donc
plusieurs minutes avant
[Musique]
un schéma du maintien de l'ordre qui est
fait pour que précisément on mette
pied-à-terre et ils ne font pas du
maintien de l'or à moto c'est la
personne qui est derrière et tout cela
ne méritait pas d'être débattue dans
l'enceinte de l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
je pense que d'abord c'est au pouvoir
politique que de préciser le maintien de
l'ordre ce n'est pas au législateur que
de dire comment nous allons faire en
sorte sur l'exécutif
mais est-ce qu'il n'y a pas eu des
sanctions administratives et judiciaires
pour les policiers de la bras la
question
si vous voulez être majoritaire dans ce
pays essayez de gagner les élections on
en reparlera après
ce que vous disiez que les
parlementaires n'ont pas de rôle à jouer
parce qu'en 2021 Emmanuel Macron avait
annoncé la création d'un comité de
contrôle de la police commuté
parlementaire qui n'a d'ailleurs jamais
vu le jour donc il y avait quand même
l'idée que les parlementaires pouvaient
discuter de ce sujet
Alexandra maçon vous entend pas beaucoup
dans le débat j'allais venir je vous
remercie de nous donner la parole je
serais quand même revenir 5 minutes en
arrière sur l'audition de Monsieur
Darman ce matin parce qu'il y a quand
même un échec malgré tout de Monsieur
Darmanin même si tout n'est pas
catastrophique c'est qu'il la redit ce
matin il y a des services de
renseignement en France qui en théorie
de devrait pas de mauvais service de
renseignement on sait que c'est à peu
près 1000 personnes à chaque
manifestation qu'elle soit d'ailleurs
légale où illégales qui sont les mêmes
qui viennent casser qui viennent polluer
ceux qui veulent manifester sereinement
parce qu'effectivement c'est un droit de
faire grève de pouvoir manifester et il
y a eu beaucoup de manifestations
légales dans lesquelles il y a eu
beaucoup de débordements donc comment on
peut aujourd'hui être face à un tel
échec de votre politique et ne pas avoir
réussi on l'a vu à Sainte solide un
certain nombre de militants qu'on
connaissait qui sont arrivés extrêmement
armés qui ont ramené ces débordements là
comment vous pouvez aujourd'hui
justifier que vos services de
renseignement
ne vous ai pas amené à les interpeller
bien en amont on sait qu'ils aient on
sait qu'ils sont arrivés de payer
étrangers qui sont arrivés ultra rare
mais on savait quel jour quelle heure
enfin tout ça on le savait là il y a un
vrai derrière votre question il y a il y
a un sous-entendu est-ce que c'est
volonté
ce matin donc je pose la question
comment expliquez-vous cela pour une
raison assez simple madame c'est que
dans notre pays il faudra pas échapper
qui a pas de présomption de culpabilité
on arrête les gens quand ils ont commis
quelque chose
ont déjà été arrêtés à plusieurs
reprises vous savez qui circulaient que
vous savez qu'ils sont ultra armés vous
savez là où ils vont vous pourriez au
moins je veux dire avoir anticipé le
fait qu'il n'accepte pas ce type de site
en février quand même je vous dis ce que
ce qui est ce que disait le patron l'a
déjà dit en février à l'Assemblée
nationale nombre de démocraties
occidentales considère que la menace
ultra droite supremaciste
la principale
on peut parler on peut parler de plein
de choses le rugbyman argent
qui je vous le rappelle est consacré à
la stratégie du maintien de l'ordre le
signal en passant je voudrais juste vous
faire réagir va-t-il panneau à l'avocat
William Bourdon ce matin qui est accusé
Gérald Darmanin d'avoir une stratégie de
maintien du désordre c'est vous partagez
ce point de vue c'est-à-dire pour vous
c'est pour vous il peut y avoir un usage
politique aujourd'hui quand je dis un
stratégie de la police c'est je dis
exactement la même chose je le dis
aujourd'hui Gérald Darmanin est
responsable du désordre dans lequel nous
sommes et ils créent des violences qui
mettent en danger les policiers et les
manifestants et je vais vous dire à
Sainte Soline quand vous voyez le nombre
de grenades qui ont été utilisés plus de
5000 grenades c'est-à-dire une toutes
les deux secondes et que personne n'a
jamais empêché je ne sais pas pourquoi
il n'y a pas eu par exemple de barrage
filtrant pour empêcher les 30 000
personnes d'arriver jusqu'à un trou de
terre où il n'y a absolument rien à
dégrader je le rappelle s'il y avait eu
un minima des barrages filtrants ce qui
a été fait à Sainte Soline et l'image
de sécurité
que le désordre ce serait l'ordre
désormais madame panneau mais n'oubliez
jamais madame panoter
il y a illégal et je vous invite à
respecter la loi ça évitera bien des
déconvenues je vous invite à respecter
les institutions de la République ça
nous évitera également
des retraites merci à tous les quatre
d'être venu débattre sur ce plateau de
Savoie Mathilde pano vous restez avec
nous puisque vous êtes notre grand
témoin ce soir dans une dizaine de
minutes ce sera autour de nos affranchis
mais ils sont déjà là regardez on vous
avait on évoquera les insoumis qui ont
été rappelés à l'ordre par le Bureau de
l'Assemblée ce sera la chronique Bourbon
Express d'Elsa mondingava Jean-Rémy
Baudot nous expliquera la stratégie
d'Elizabeth Bor ne sur l'épineux dossier
des retraites enfin on verra avec Thomas
l'estavel ce qui anime Anne Hidalgo dans
sa croisade contre les trottinettes en
libre service mais d'abord notre grand
témoin je vous le disais Mathilde panot
qui a une actualité chargée cette
semaine avec la réforme des retraites
évidemment une défaite électorale pour
la France insoumise en arrière et des
critiques qui se font jour au sein de la
nuque mais si on vous invite Mathilde
panneau ce n'est pas seulement pour
parler de cela explication de Marco
pommier
si on vous invite Mathilde panot c'est
parce que vous êtes en première ligne
contre la réforme des retraites à
quelques jours de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel
farouche opposante à Emmanuel Macron
dans la rue comme à l'Assemblée jamais
[Musique]
applaudi par les vôtres les 74 députés
insoumis sous votre houlette à la tête
de la France insoumise depuis 2021 vous
êtes la plus jeune présidente d'un
groupe à l'Assemblée Jean-Luc Mélenchon
ne tarit pas d'éloches sur votre
personne une trajectoire fulgurante
députée du Val-de-Marne vous faites vos
premiers pas de militante à lunettes
première manif en 2005 contre le CPE à
votre arrivée à Sciences Po c'est le
choc des cultures dites-vous votre
moteur d'engagement la volonté de faire
bouger les choses et un sentiment de
révolte la politique pour moi c'est ce
qui m'a permis de sortir la boule de
rage que j'avais dans les tripes en
quelque chose de positif votre marque de
fabrique les coûts d'éclat médiatique
dont vous avez le secret
en fait qu'un seul geste en direction du
peuple vous le bâillonnez
bref vous faites souvent le buzz mais
vous l'assumez quitte à déraper madame
Bob et indignation dans la classe
politique le père de la première
ministre était un rescapé du Kanta aux
Juifs accusé d'antisémitisme ce jour-là
vous plaît dès la maladresse des
polémiques mais aussi des victoires
lorsque l'assemblée adopte votre
proposition de loi sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
historique aujourd'hui
vous en êtes l'un des visages
emblématiques cette coalition des
gauches parfois bien divisée sur sa
stratégie le communiste Fabien Roussel
parle d'une alliance dépassée et vous
Mathilde pano qu'en pensez-vous la
nupesse a-t-elle du plomb dans l'aile
on va commencer par ça si vous le voulez
bien Mathilde panot cette déclaration de
Fabien Roussel qui juge la nupesse
dépassée il faut rassembler bien au-delà
nous devons parler à toute la gauche
dit-il d'abord sur le fond c'est un
débat légitime selon vous débattre
aujourd'hui du périmètre de cette
alliance politique tout est légitime
mais moi je commence par noter quelque
chose la nups elle est née en 13 jours
et en 13 nuits suite aux élections
présidentielles et au choix qui avaient
été fait par les électeurs et les
électrices et qui a permis de donner
cette alliance autour d'un programme de
gouvernement et ensuite c'est 151
députés de la nuit Pesse avec une
multiplication par 5 du nombre de
députés dans le groupe insoumis donc
depuis le premier jour on nous explique
que le lendemain et la semaine d'après à
chaque fois la nuit pèse va se fissurer
moi je note que depuis 9 mois la nuit
pèse se consolide mais je vais dire là
où j'ai eu un point de désaccord très
fort avec Monsieur Roussel sur cette
question c'est que quand il dit il faut
qu'elle s'élargisse
notamment avec monsieur Cazeneuve qui
note et qui qui prend comme exemple là
je ne suis pas d'accord parce que nous
n'avons pas de coin commun avec Monsieur
Cazeneuve monsieur Cazeneuve je le
rappelle était ministre du Budget
lorsque le nombre d'annuités des
retraites a été augmentées il était
ministre de l'intérieur lorsque Rémi
Fraisse a été tué et je le dis nous ce
qui relie la nupesse c'est un programme
de gouvernement et ce programme de
gouvernement compte un nombre de mesures
extrêmement fortes et c'est autour de ça
que nous travaillons et que je crois
nous construisons quelque chose qui est
un espoir immense pour des millions de
gens ça c'est sur le fond sur la forme
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec vos alliés
communistes on a l'impression qu'il y a
vraiment des tensions extrêmes d'un côté
LFI de l'autre les communistes on a vu
des règlements de compte sur Twitter
notamment Paul Vanier député LFI qui en
réaction propose à Fabien Roussel de se
consacrer à l'organisation de son
barbecue avec Bernard Cazeneuve et de
laisser la nuit pèse tranquille son
petit jeu de diviseur nous a déjà coûté
le second tour de la présidentielle ça
donne l'impression que vous avez du mal
à vous parler en interne à dialoguer
sans mettre tout sur la place publique
comme ça je crois pas qu'on est des
problèmes avec des communistes mais
c'est vrai c'est un problème personnel
avec Fabien Roussel c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de dire régulier avec des
prises de parole de Monsieur Roussel qui
vont à l'encontre non seulement de notre
programme mais de ce que nous essayons
de construire collectivement et je le
dis c'est une difficulté mais comme vous
le voyez depuis 9 mois nous avons fait
un nombre de propositions de loi avec
l'ensemble des groupes de la minute et
qui sont énormes en termes de travail
législatif à partir de notre programme
de gouvernement nous avons fait des
notions ensemble nous venons de déposer
une saisine à l'aide d'aller défendre
notre saisine au Conseil constitutionnel
ensemble donc peut-être y a-t-il un
problème avec Monsieur Roussel je
l'admets mais cela n'engage en rien le
fait que la nuit pêche continue de se
consolider et que je vois plutôt que
c'est du côté de la macronie voir des LR
que là vous avez des divisions qui sont
extrêmement fortes et qui devraient vous
inquiéter une question tout donne sur la
place que prend la France insoumise dans
les décisions stratégiques de la nup il
a quand même été contesté récemment par
tous vos partenaires sur la réforme des
retraites sur le fait de refuser de
débattre de ce fameux article 7 qui
décalé l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite est-ce que vous assumez que
vous elle est fi première force
politique de la nups doit pouvoir
imposer ses décisions aux autres
partenaires de temps en temps c'est pas
une question d'imposer des décisions
c'est une question que nous avons quatre
groupes dans dans l'inter-groupe et que
oui nous assumons que nous avons le
droit d'être maître de notre stratégie
en 17 stratégie s'impose aux autres
c'est-à-dire que votre stratégie c'est
imposée au communistes aux écologistes
au socialistes stratégique et je dois
dire que je suis assez fier que nous
ayons réussi et ça c'est pour le coup
avec l'ensemble de laupes à lever nombre
de mensonges sur la réforme des
retraites notamment sur qui toucherait
les 1200 euros brut puisqu'on est passé
de tout le monde à 1,8 millions à 40 000
personnes puis finalement à 10 à 20 000
personnes seulement dans le pays qui
toucherait ses 1200 euros brut mais
aussi que nous nous ayons fait en sorte
que ce texte n'est aucune légitimité
parlementaire et je crois que c'est ce
qui a permis de donner du temps
justement au mouvement social de pouvoir
s'organiser et quand on voit ce qui
s'est passé au Sénat je crois que ça
nous donne raison sur la stratégie que
nous avons eu j'aimerais qu'on évoque à
présent cette élection législative
partielle qui s'est déroulée dimanche en
arrière et qui a vu la député sortante
de la France insoumise Bénédicte taurine
battue par une dissidente socialiste
Martine Froget alors la majorité
présidentielle avait appelé à voter en
faveur de la dissidente socialiste on a
vu se dessiner dans cette parcelle une
sorte de front anti LFI qui a fonctionné
quelles leçons est-ce que vous tirez
alors là la première chose c'est je veux
quand même redire ici mon affection à la
fois pour Bénédicte et l'ensemble des
militants qui ont mené une campagne
d'une grande dignité là ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que évidemment lorsque on a soit des
tireurs dans le dos soit de la division
et bien cela permet d'avoir
effectivement quelque chose qui se crée
qui soit tout sauf les filles il ne faut
pas s'y tromper à la fin c'est tout sauf
la nups aussi qui se crée donc est-ce
que c'est pas aussi votre place au sein
de la nupette votre capacité à
rassembler toute la gauche qui peut se
retrouver remise en question par cette
stratégie on a le sentiment en fait vous
avez tellement mis vos adversaires sur
les nerfs qui sont prêts à tout pour
vous faire battre je crois pas parce que
si Madame projet avait eu une réelle
étiquette macroniste il se serait passé
ce qui s'est passé au premier tour
peut-être avez-vous regardé les
résultats attentivement mais la
candidature macroniste au premier tour
est passé de 19,5 à 10% seulement donc
si elle avait eu une étiquette
Renaissance pure et dure et bien elle
n'aurait pas été élue donc je le dis
c'est que socialiste est-ce que
maintenant l'étiquette socialiste n'est
pas devenue plus rassembleuse que ne
pourrait l'être l'étiquette LFI
je ne crois pas et je crois que y
compris ce que nous construisons
ensemble avec la nupes doit alerter
chacun et chacune de se dire que nous ne
devons pas donner en quelque sorte des
permis de division à tout va et que
chacun des parlementaires de la nuit
parce que nous sommes sont concernés par
le fait que si il y a une candidature de
division qui se met et bien cela met en
cause à la fois le fait d'avoir des
députés de la nupesse mais aussi du coup
l'élection éventuelle de macronistes ou
encore pire de députés du rassemblement
national comme on l'a vu dans
l'hémicycle mais je dois vous dire
quelque chose quand même parce que quand
on fait le bilan des quatre législatifs
partielles qu'il y a eu depuis janvier
le résultat c'est de nupes et moins un
RN voilà le résultat de ces élections et
notamment nous nous avons gagné René
Pilato qui a été élu en Charente donc je
ne crois pas non que vous puissiez tirer
des conclusions qui laissent à penser
que la France insoumise apparaîtrait
comme un épouvantail extraordinaire qui
ferait que on ne puisse pas être élu oui
donc quand sur une candidature il y a
une alliance et qui est manœuvrière
entre de renaissance jusqu'à l'extrême
droite puisque monsieur Odoul c'est
félicité de la victoire de Madame Froget
et bien oui à ce moment-là nous perdons
mais ce n'est pas ce qui se passe
cette défaite ne va pas du tout remettre
en cause votre stratégie qu'on peut
appeler du bruit et de la fureur dans
l'hémicycle pour vous il y a pas de lien
entre les deux ça ne va pas écouter les
fraisiers une partie d'électorat de
gauche elle a fait 8 millions de voix à
l'élection présidentielle d'accord nous
avons fait 22 % et ce que nous faisons
et justifier encore aujourd'hui oui
parce que je vais vous expliquer ce qui
se justifie d'avoir à la fois un
programme de rupture ce que nous avons
avec laupes d'avoir à la fois une
crédibilité très forte parce que nous
avons des spécialistes sur tous les
sujets qui ont traduit en loi absolument
tout ce que nous avons proposé dans le
programme et qui montre que oui nous
sommes prêts avec la nupesse à remplacer
un gouvernement qui aujourd'hui à bout
de souffle et je l'espère même un
président alors sur la réforme des
retraites à présent la rencontre entre
Elisabeth borne et l'Inter syndicale à
la Matignon a été un échec ce sont les
mots employés par les syndicats ce matin
pas question de retirer la réforme ni de
revenir sur les 64 ans cette réforme
elle a été adoptée le gouvernement ne
veut pas la retirer c'est quoi la suite
pour vous comment est-ce que vous
comptez maintenir la mobilisation
sociale en attendant la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel alors déjà je
veux saluer l'Inter syndical qui je
crois en quelque sorte fait un geste
fort au moment où la macronie cette
semaine a décidé d'essayer de tourner la
page de la réforme des retraites en
disant que c'était fini et qu'on allait
parler d'autre chose non on ne parle pas
d'autre chose quand c'est une réforme
qui va toucher la chair des gens la vie
des gens mais la suite c'est quoi pour
vous évidemment c'est demain là les
normes mobilisation qu'il va y avoir
partout dans le pays et j'invite toutes
celles et ceux qui le peuvent attendre
avec des grèves qui recommencent avec
des piquets et des blocages un peu
partout donc ça c'est la première chose
et puis ensuite la deuxième chose c'est
que je vous disais tout à l'heure nous
avons fait une saisie nos conseils
constitutionnel peut-être que c'est le
Conseil constitutionnel qui nous
permettra de sortir par le haut de
l'impasse démocratique dans lequel le
Président nous a placé parce que nous
avons d'excellents arguments pour dire
que cette loi est inconstitutionnelle et
j'espère que c'est la vie qui rendra le
Conseil constitutionnel en tout cas
c'est une nouvelle étape et cette lutte
va continuer quoi qu'il en soit
la nouvelle secrétaire général de la CGT
Sophie Binet les relations entre les
filles et Philippe Martinez étaient
plutôt fraîches vous avez bon espoir que
les choses s'améliorent avec elle j'ai
écouté avec intérêt lorsqu'elle disait
qu'elle voulait normalisation des
relations avec les organisations
politiques et je pense que c'est
important puisque nous partageons un
objectif commun qui est le retrait de
cette réforme des retraites à 64 ans
merci ma petite panneau vous restez avec
nous puisqu'on accueille à présent nos
affranchis installez-vous messieurs
dames avec Jean-Rémy Baudot de France
Info Thomas l'estavel qui est
journaliste éco à L'Express et au Figaro
notamment et on commence avec vous Elsa
mandingava avec Bourbon Express vous
nous racontez l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée Elsa oui je vais vous
raconter ce soir l'histoire de la
réunion du bureau de l'Assemblée qui
s'est un peu transformé en procès des
insoumis ou plutôt en procès de vote
comportement Mathilde pano et vos
troupes dans l'hémicycle alors première
accusé Hugo Bernal ici charge retenu
contre lui il twitch dans l'hémic alors
les plus jeunes auront peut-être compris
pour les téléspectateurs qui ont besoin
des explications twitch c'est un réseau
social que le début twitch comme il
s'appelle utilise et pour diffuser et
commenter en direct les séances dans
l'hémicycle après plusieurs
avertissements il est sanctionné c'était
le 20 mars dernier
vous voulez continuer alors vous voulez
continuer je vais donc saisir le bureau
de cela et je vous inflige je me suis
bien investisse un rappel règlement avec
inscription procès-verbal article 71 et
on y va alors la réunion du bureau elle
s'est tenue ce matin le député a pu
plaider sa cause et on l'a retrouvé
c'est par hasard il était en train de
faire une vidéo pour expliquer ce qui
s'était passé lors de la réunion c'était
pas sur twitch mais il a aussi
évidemment et heureusement répondu à nos
questions
je plaide pour que tout le monde puisse
avoir cette liberté alors pas forcément
de filmer les autres mais au moins de se
filmer soi-même à partir du moment où on
trouble pas la séance en tant que tel
donc c'est ça le l'enjeu mais à
contrario c'est vrai que j'ai déclaré
j'ai dit si vous me sanctionnez moi pour
ça alors attendez vous à ce que
n'importe qui qui procéderait à des
enregistrements des captations ou des
communications avec l'extérieur
d'ailleurs qui n'ont pas besoin d'être
public dans le règlement pour être
poursuivi c'est à dire qu'un message
WhatsApp un message télégramme un sms
même pourrait être poursuivi en fait en
réalité par ce par cette par ce
règlement donc vous allez maintenant
rappel au règlement pour dénoncer des
collègues ou vous jugerez ce qu'ils font
n'est pas tout à fait dans le règlement
bah écoutez toutes choses étant égale
par ailleurs je veux pas pourquoi je
serai le seul à perdre un quart de mon
indemnité voilà puisque la sanction
prononcée dans l'hémicycle était déjà
effectivement alors les questions de se
limitent pas à twitch il y a un groupe
de travail qui va se pencher sur tous
les usages de des nouveaux outils de
communication exactement c'est la
députée du Val d'Oise Naima muchu qui
est député horizon vice-présidente de
l'Assemblée qui aura justement la charge
de cette réflexion elle nous explique en
quoi va consister sa mission
c'est vrai que maintenant dans
l'assemblée on twitch on tweet on fait
des vidéos vous allez faire un peu le
ménage en tout ça oui c'est ça c'est
absolument ça on est confronté à
l'Assemblée nationale nous aussi comme
la société à l'arrivée de ces nouveaux
moyens de communication le règlement de
l'Assemblée est pas forcément adapté il
faut apporter des réponses parce qu'on a
des députés youtubeurs qui font des
twitchs dans l'hémicycles enfin voilà
toutes ces questions qui se posent sur
lesquelles on doit apporter un certain
nombre de réponses au moins définir un
nouveau cadre alors c'est pas la seule
sanction dont on a parlé ce matin parce
que les insoumis ont été sanctionnés
mais collectivement oui vous allez
mettre-t-il panneau vous et les députés
de votre groupe recevoir par courrier un
rappel à l'ordre c'est la plus faible
des sanctions qui existent à l'Assemblée
mais c'est tout de même une sanction et
la cause c'est ça souvenez-vous
[Applaudissements]
le 16 mars dernier vous vous en souvenez
Elisabeth borne déclenche le 49-3 enfin
elle tente plutôt de le faire puisque
dans l'hémicycle l'atmosphère est
survolté est-ce qu'on vous a sanctionné
pour vos pancartes pour avoir chanté la
Marseillaise ou pour un tumulte
généralisé bah écoutez nous nos
ascendants d'avoir les considérants
exacts parce que justement il y a un
flou j'avais indiqué que des pancartes
il en a été brandi différentes
entreprises notamment quelques temps
après cette séance du 16 mars lors de la
motion de censure effectivement le fait
de cibler ce moment là ce 16 mars pour
nous sanctionner nous parce que c'est
une sanction le fait de choisir de nous
adresser à nous ce rappel à l'ordre par
courrier bah c'est c'est un message
politique alors pour être tout à fait
complète ce ne sont pas il y a pas que
les insoumis qui vont être sanctionnés
puisqu'il y a aussi des députés qui ont
tweeté pendant la commission mixte
paritaire et aussi des députés qui ont
été il y a aussi vous mais il y avait
aussi des socialistes il me semble et
des députés qui ont été équipés de micro
dans l'hémicycle et suivi par des
caméras de télévision ceci aussi et
comprendre un rappel à l'ordre merci
el-za mandingava et une réaction quand
même à se rappeler à la lourde collectif
Mathilde panot deux on est en train de
franchir des seuils qui sont pour moi
une acceptables tout le monde se pleure
à chaud de larmes sur l'abstention
lorsque il y a des élections et lorsque
vous avez twitch il faut comprendre
c'est la vidéo de l'Assemblée avec juste
un chat sur lequel on échange avec des
gens avec des gens qui suivent ce n'est
pas en train de parler dans un micro
dans l'hémicy donc ça ne dérange en rien
la séance et ça permet à plein de gens
de suivre la séance d'une autre manière
je crois que ça développe un intérêt
pour la politique et que par ailleurs
les assemblées sont publiques dans ce
pays et elles sont publiques partout ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que je vais beaucoup
m'amuser à voir comment ils vont
sanctionner les gens qui vont chanter la
Marseillaise images qui a fait le tour
du monde parce que alors vous avez d'un
côté André torignat député de mon groupe
qui elle était malade et chantait la
Marseillaise avec nous depuis sa télé
j'attends de voir s'ils vont la
sanctionner s'il va regarder sur la
vidéo si il y a des bas pour lui
elle aussi chanter est-ce que c'est la
pancarte qui est sanctionnée ou la
Marseillaise il y a des barres puisque
ça serait pour chahut donc c'est le
secret plutôt les pancartes pour
l'instant parce que si c'est les
pancartes alors pourquoi pas faire la
séance d'après la semaine d'après ou
justement on a fait là aussi des
émotions de sanctions
qui nous emmène vers des franchissements
de seuil autoritaires qui je crois sont
dangereux pour notre assemblée on reste
dans l'actualité politique avec vous
Jean-Rémy Baudot après présent on vient
de parler de la rencontre de
l'intersyndical avec elsaborne à
Matignon ça a duré 55 minutes c'est
grave alors vous savez ce soit aussi
court politique parfois une mauvaise
réunion vaut mieux qu'une que pas de
réunion du tout au sein du gouvernement
en tout cas on se satisfait que déjà
personne n'est claqué la porte que tout
le monde ait joué le jeu ça a de la
valeur de se parler même si c'est pour
rater des désaccords explique un
ministre qui était présent ce matin un
membre du gouvernement qui juge
d'ailleurs qu'il vaut mieux une
discussion qui tourne au cours plutôt
que d'avoir à assumer l'idée d'être
insensible au dialogue au sortir de
cette réunion on se souvient d'Elizabeth
borne qui a dit que c'était une réunion
qui marquait une étape importante et
c'est vrai en tout cas pour le
gouvernement parce que à défaut de
reprendre la main à défaut d'avoir
l'opinion de son côté bien l'annonce de
cette réunion a permis de gagner du
temps selon l'exécutif depuis qu'on sait
que cette réunion va avoir lieu on a eu
finalement beaucoup de réactions ça a
occupé beaucoup l'espace médiatique et
politique on a moins parlé des
manifestations en tout cas c'est comme
ça que des ministres le voient bref
l'exécutif a gagné du temps et que
compte faire l'exécutif maintenant
d'abord attendre attendre ce qui va se
passer demain quelle mobilisation demain
dans la rue le gouvernement mis aussi
sur une forme d'essoufflement du
mouvement il y a le début des vacances
samedi dans certaines régions et
attendre aussi évidemment comme tout le
monde la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel là encore le
gouvernement gagne du temps et puis en
fonction de la décision embrayée sur de
nouvelles réformes avec pourquoi pas une
loi travail par exemple pour remettre au
propre ce qui aurait été censuré par le
Conseil et Isabelle borne dans tout ça
ayant privé Emmanuel Macron loue la
manière dont elle traverse les
différentes contestations a-t-il prévu
pour autant de changer de Première
ministre personne ne se risque à se
pronostic parce que même les ministres
les plus ambitieux et bien ils essaient
de freiner en fait disons-le pour eux ce
serait vraiment finalement pas vraiment
le moment de reprendre la barre dans la
période alors est-ce qu’un gouvernement
plus tourné vers la droite par ailleurs
offrirait plus de voix l'assemblée ça
franchement rien ne le dit sans boule de
cristal on peut se dire que oui on peut
s'attendre à un remaniement dans les
prochaines semaines pour passer à autre
chose mais quelle équipe pour quel
projet parce qu'en réalité c'est quand
même ça la question quel projet
politique c'est quand même ça
l'incertitude à quoi penser manuel
Macron pour la suite pour l'instant
c'est peut-être lui qui gagne du temps
Merci à VOUS Jean-Rémy bodot ma petite
pano je vais pas vous faire redire ce
que vous avez déjà dit sur la réforme de
retraite l'Inter syndicale mais
peut-être un mot sur Elizabeth borne
vous souhaitez son départ aujourd'hui de
Matignon une première ministre qui n'a
jamais demandé la confiance à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui depuis
alors le centième 49,3 de la Cinquième
République le dernier 49-3 qu'elle a
utilisé sur la question des retraites
pour passer en force et largement
affaibli dans le pays et moi je veux
dire que je pense que ce pouvoir n'a pas
compris ce pourquoi les gens se
battaient et eux le voient évidemment
comme une réforme comptable avec des
choses bon deux ans voilà trois mois
pour certains quatre mois pour d'autres
mais ils n'ont pas compris que ce qui
était en train de se jouer pour le
peuple français c'était à la fois une
question dignité une question d'humanité
et une question vraiment de vision de
société et notamment de d'engagement
politique citoyen associatifs ou même
d'engagement avec ces petits-enfants et
que c'était ça qui était touché
aujourd'hui avec la réforme des
retraites et qui ne s'arrêtera pas parce
que il se battent par semaine
constitutionnel dans tous les cas ça
changerait rien de Premier ministre si
si cette pâte sur ça il y aura pas de
retour normal
ESTAVEL c'est à vous vous êtes
journaliste économique notamment pour
L'Express Le Figaro et alors vous vous
félicitez de la fin des trottinettes en
libre-service à Paris avec les Parisiens
qui ont massivement voté contre cette
trottinette à 90% vous aussi oui faites
partie des 90% alors je vais vous
expliquer en fait il y a deux raisons
majeures la première c'est que bon
n'importe qui peut emprunter ces
fameuses trottinettes d'autres lime on
voit partout dans nos rues à Paris en
tout cas même des gens qui conduisent un
peu n'importe comment parce qu'ils ont
pas l'habitude or c'est beaucoup plus
dangereux qu'un vélo de manière très
pragmatique vous avez pas de casque
l'équilibre un peu instable et les
personnes âgées n'osent plus traverser
les passages piétons de peur d'être
percuté par un fou du guidon ça c'est la
première chose mais la deuxième mais qui
est presque plus importante c'est que
contrairement aux trottinette électrique
que vous possédez que vous achetez chez
Darty ou chez Decathlon celles qui sont
louées en libre-service c'est une
véritable aberration écologique d'après
une étude lors durée de vie est de 28
jours donc même pas un mois avant
qu'elle ne finisse à la casse ou au fond
de la scène ou du canal Saint-Martin or
pour les fabriquer il faut des métaux
rares qui en passant sont exploités en
Chine ou en Afrique dans des conditions
déplorables et enfin les trottinettes ne
diminuent pas la pollution puisqu'elles
viennent en remplacement de la marche à
pied ou du vélo alors c'est pas la
première fois que la mère de Paris
s'attaque aux entrepreneurs du numérique
ça vous a pas échappé c'est loin d'être
le premier combat d'Anne Hidalgo face
aux étoiles montantes du web et je pense
qu'à la raison alors si vous vous
souvenez on peut remonter il y a
quelques années la fronde contre les VTC
donc qui concurrençaient les taxis qui
eux doivent payer une licence et puis
plus récemment uber Bolt et freina qui
avait été contesté parce qu'ils prennent
des auto-entrepreneurs et c'est du
salariat déguisé alors réaction de la
mère de Paris elle avait réussi en 2020
à faire interdire au VTC la rue de
Rivoli et puis et forcément le cas
Airbnb qui remonte encore avant très
néfaste pour les Parisiens puisque les
propriétaires préférait évidemment
mettre leur appartement sur la
plateforme à l'année plutôt que de louer
à ceux qui ont vraiment besoin les
étudiants les jeunes actifs etc et pour
ce cas là la mairie de Paris a réussi à
obtenir la fameuse limite des 120 jours
par an donc vous vous estimez que les
pouvoirs publics doivent être plus
stricts avec ces sociétés du web qui
souvent sont aussi un peu fragiles
économiquement quand elle débute alors
ça c'est un peu le discours ambiant mais
c'est pas vraiment une raison alors déjà
quand on regarde les montants qui ont
été levés l'an dernier par la french
tech et des montants très
impressionnants et records plus de 13
milliards d'euros et puis c'est des
sociétés qui respectent pas toujours la
loi et le code du travail c'est à dire
la base de la base si vous regardez il y
a des startups comme Lydia kappa ou en
e-commerce qui s'appelait avant wind
elles ont été épinglées sur Internet et
même parfois au tribunal pour management
toxique pratique commerciale trompeuses
ou encore des soucis avec les
prud'hommes bref la startup nation c'est
bien mais le respect de la loi c'est
bien aussi Merci à VOUS Thomas l'estavel
ma petite panneau vous êtes trottinette
vous ça vous arrive de les utiliser mais
j'ai appris je savais pas que c'était 28
jours la durée moyenne de vie d'une
trottinette qui est quand même assez
incroyable et je pense que c'est ça
attire aussi un fil de si on laisse le
marché décider tout seul de tas de
choses on arrive vers des sociétés qui
sont chaotiques et donc je pense qu'à la
fois les règles qui permettent de lutter
contre une numérisation de la société
généralisée et le fait de développer les
services publics sont des choses bien
plus vous êtes en accord avec un Hidalgo
mais il y avait quand même 800 emplois
en jeu sur les emplois on peut savoir à
quoi on veut les utiliser parce que on a
dit exactement la même chose sur les
uber et à la fin on voit bien ça tire
les droits des travailleurs de tout le
monde vers le bas et ça détruit des
emplois ça crée des emplois qui sont
généralement des emplois de mauvaise
qualité et donc je préfère qu'on tire
tout le monde vers le haut et il y a
quand même beaucoup de choses à faire
dans notre pays dans lequel on pourrait
créer des emplois à commencer par
l'hôpital public les EHPAD et beaucoup
d'autres emplois la RATP et d'autres
merci beaucoup mathildeau d'avoir été
notre grand témoin ce soir merci à tous
les trois nos affranchis tout de suite
émissions spéciales à suivre sur SCP
convention citoyenne une loi pour
choisir sa mort avec Myriam en Kawa et
ses invités bonne soirée et à bientôt
sur LCP
[Musique]